on my show I we it's it's you know it
was like uh everyone loved the bad boy
everyone loved uh Damon and then there's
like the occasional like I like Stefan
and in the back in the back like you
know yeah everyone she gets booed and
there's Tomatoes did you uh when did you
really start becoming close friends with
Ian was it immediate yeah it was pretty
immediate Ian and I uh uh are like we're
totally different human beings I mean
like you could not we are like oil and
vinegar in that sense and I think I
think but that that worked well for us
in a yin and yang way it worked great
for our on-screen chemistry it worked
great for sort of having the two
brothers being Polar Opposites yin and
yang energy and we just really kind of
understood immediately that we would
work well together and that we could
create a really good uh dramatic uh
television series with our different
personalities and I think that lended
itself lends itself to our relationship
off screen which we sort of are very
similar now we have a business together
and it's like you know Brothers Bond
Bourbon Brothers Bond bourbon where can
they get that in stores anywhere
anywhere Amazon yeah actually anywhere
yeah Brothers Bond Bourbon and it's
doing well it's it's doing a straight
bourbon whiskey yeah we have we have uh
you can get Brothers bun I'm gonna get a
bottle you should I am I'm gonna buy it
you can literally go down to Whole Foods
and grab a bottle
um how about the uh Country Store
uh maybe they might have it I don't know
so it's it's some of the some of the
smaller shops it's like it's like hit or
miss but uh we're big online and um more
more so uh in getting more and more into
like restaurants and bars and stuff but
this uh like you know the business that
we started it's doing really well and
it's like we approach it completely
differently and that's what's great
about it we have a complete yin and yang
approach Ian's like oh my God optimism
positive positive and I'm like here's
the worst case scenario and which is
most likely to happen yeah this is you
know this is we're all gonna you know
we're gonna go bankrupt and then so we
we meet in the middle you know I do that
with my my friend Tom we're doing some
kind of product I won't say what it is
yet but we just met the guy who's the
manufacturer and I'm like so uh uh he's
like going it's easy you just you buy
this many at this month they have it's
all it's all done all right Insurance
wise right how does this work right and
I'm like wait a minute wait a minute we
can't get sued no no it's on the
manufacturer oh can you give me that in
writing my business manager's on the
phone I want this to be legit all right
so you and Ian have been friends for
many many years you still have this
friendship
um you have this bourbon uh it's yeah
it's incredible you talk how often oh my
god dude I mean it's a full-time job
it's like it's it's absolutely insane I
mean every day emails threads uh text
messages we have employees we have um
you know we have an office we have um I
mean where's your office
we have well Ian and I have like a
little office in Malibu actually that we
share is just like our little Studio
we'll we'll do
um you know taste things or zooms and
things of that nature and you know but
then our our most of our our team is in
Texas and believe it or not Canada but
um man it's a whole thing it started out
as this covid project we were like hey
let's just make a bourbon well we talked
about it you I don't know if you ever
saw vampires but all we did was drink
bourbon I mean it was like a thing it
was like so we wanted to do Urban
brothers it makes perfect sense well
that by the way so all the fans would
say like you know when when we would do
these like conventions or something they
would say like you know why don't you
guys have a bourbon why don't you guys
have a bourbon and uh so many years they
were saying that we kept saying why why
aren't we doing this and we finally did
it so it was like one of those things
we've been talking about a friend we've
been drinking bourbon forever you know
we shot in the South wow we shot the
pilot in Vancouver and then we moved the
series to Atlanta right to Atlanta all
bourbon down there I love so